après les deux grandes manifestations du
week-end passé après d'autres
rassemblements plus modestes comme celui
de toulouse hier les instances de
l'enseignement catholique présentait
donc aujourd'hui leur dernière
contre-proposition au projet savary vous
souvenez certainement que les partisans
du privé avaient déjà accepté deux
points de ce plan le premier porte sur
les modalités de création et de
fermetures de classes
quant au second il détermine les
rapports entre les pouvoirs publics et
les établissements privés de poing selon
lesquelles un accord a d'ores et déjà
été trouvés restait deux autres
propositions elles ont été rejetés dès
l'origine par les tenants du privé qui
présentait donc aujourd'hui leurs contre
propositions
tout de suite les détails avec estelle
goût si à la place des établissements
d'intérêt public envisagé par le
ministre de l'éducation l'enseignement
catholique propose de nouvelles
structures adaptées elles aussi à la
décentralisation
le groupement public d'intérêt éducatif
cette structure réunir est
obligatoirement les établissements
privés sous contrat d'une même région
elle servirait d'intermédiaire entre
pouvoirs publics et établissements
privés notamment en ce qui concerne le
financement dans les conseils
d'administration de ces groupements la
majorité des sièges reviendrait aux
représentants des établissements privés
contrairement à la proposition de
monsieur savary le groupement aurait un
caractère public puisque le commissaire
de la république exercerait sur lui une
tutelle administrative toutefois
l'enseignement catholique demandent que
le régime des contrats demeure et que
les établissements conservent leur
autonomie
sur le second point de désaccord le
statut des enseignants l'enseignement
catholique qui refuse la
fonctionnarisation des maîtres du privé
propose un statut spécifique
les enseignants seraient toujours sous
contrat mais ces contrats seraient
passés par l'intermédiaire de nouvelles
commissions comprenant des représentants
de l'enseignement privé mais aussi
publics le pouvoir des chefs
d'établissement du privé serait ainsi
réduit la garantie de l'emploi étant
fondée sur des accords passés avec
l'état nous avions toujours dit que les
effets
nous les refusions parce qu ils nous
mettaient sous la dépendance des
collectivités de calais et à ce que nous
proposons conserve toute l'autonomie
pour les collectivités terrible pour les
établissements par rapport aux
collectivités territoriales et par
rapport à l'état est-ce que les
manifestations qui ont lieu depuis deux
mois vous aident à négocier bien je le
pense c'est pour ça que nous les
continueront qu'est ce que vous ferez si
vous contre-proposition font refuser par
le ministre nous réunirons le comité
national et décideront de notre attitude